cette
affaire
je rencontrais d'ananas qui va devenir
ma femme
[Musique]
je veux dire une chose je vis
et comment tu es devenu une si grande
comédie lançant c'est toute ma vie
[Musique]
tu sais que je suis ouais et tu sais qui
c'est ma copine barbra streisand part de
streisand s'en sort comme dans ce
scandale comme nos ressentiments bras
streisand non
streisand
[Musique]
c'est le destin qui nous a réunis
nous ont menés jusqu'ici
[Musique]
je vais parce qu'il concerne affaire
tu veux voir munitions pas
je peux toucher
[Musique]
trouve ça bizarre que je traîne tout le
temps avec gary
moi je trouve bizarre de traîner tout le
temps avec gary et sa bande de potes de
15 ans fait
[Musique]
m
jamais je n'oublierai je te jure
[Musique]
et tu n'oublieras pas lequel
oh
[Musique]
sabean
baisse
la pomme
[Musique]
jarry
allo
[Musique]